OPTIMISM MACHINE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
>> Laura: LAST NIGHT IN HIS
FIRST STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS, THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERED WHAT WAS PERHAPS
THE MOST ROBUST DEFENSE OF
>> THE STATE OF OUR UNION IS
AMERICAN MOMENT.
YOU CAN DREAM ANYTHING.
YOU CAN BE ANYTHING, AND
TOGETHER WE CAN ACHIEVE
ABSOLUTELY ANYTHING.
>> Laura: WOW.
NOW, MY QUESTION IS, WHEN WE
HAVE THIS PRECIOUS GIFT,
LIBERTY, THAT MEN AND WOMEN
FLAG, OUR COUNTRY.
WHY WOULDN'T EVERYONE
BELIEVE THAT IT'S ALL WORTH
PROTECTING AND PRESERVING?
PROTECTING?
>> MY DUTY AND THE SACRED
DUTY OF EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THIS CHAMBER, IS
TO DEFEND AMERICANS, TO
PROTECT THEIR SAFETY, THEIR
FAMILIES, THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR RIGHT TO THE
>> Laura: OH NOW, THAT LAST
LINE SENT THE NEVER TRUMP
MEDIA RIGHT OVER THE EDGE.
>> YOU SAW A DIVISIVE
IMMIGRATION.
THE SCARE TACTICS OF MS-13.
IT WAS A SPEECH DELIVERED
ALMOST FROM AN ALTERNATE
REALITY.
>> YOU TELL ME THAT THAT
ROOM IS SUPPOSED TO RESPOND
LIKE THIS TO THE GREAT
DICTATOR?
I THINK THE FRAME THAT THEY
FELT IN THE ROOM WAS ONE
THAT INFLAMED THE CULTURAL
DIVIDE.
>> Laura: ONLY OVER AT THAT
OTHER CAPABLE NETWORK WOULD
DEFENDING AMERICANS AND
AMERICA BE CONTROVERSIAL.
WHEN THEIR PRESIDENT STANDS
UP FOR THEM AS A CHEERLEADER
FOR THEM.
TRUMP LOOKED PAST THE
DESPERATE DETRACTORS AND
TOWARD TRUE AMERICAN HEROES,
THE OFFICER WHO ADOPTED THE
CHILD OF A WOMAN ON DRUGS.
FAMILIES WHO SUFFERED THE
DEATH OF CHILDREN AT THE
HANDS OF MS-13 AND BY THE
WAY, WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES
DEFECTORS WHO ESCAPED OTHERS
TO DO THE SAME.
THE PRESIDENT CELEBRATED OUR
ANTHEM, THE MILITARY,
FAMILIES, AND FAITH.
AND, OF COURSE, THE CREATION
OF 2 MILLION NEW JOBS.
EMPLOYEE BOBBY
EMPLOYEE BONBY
BUSINESS INVESTMENT,
OPTIMISM, ALL GOOD STUFF.
DEMOCRATS ARE SEETHING
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY CAN'T
EVEN BEAR TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GOOD.
THEY CAN'T EVEN FAIN THE
APPEARANCE OF BEING HAPPY
AND GOOD NEWS THE AMERICANS
RAILS.
THE DEMOCRATS, I THINK, HAVE
ALLOWED THEIR PERSONAL
THAT'S HAPPENING AROUND
THEM.
NOW, LOOK AT THE CBS SNAP
POLL TAKEN RIGHT AFTER THE
PRESIDENT'S BIG SPEECH LAST
NIGHT.
8 IN 10 AMERICANS WHO
WATCHED THE STATE OF THE
UNITE THE COUNTRY.
TWO THIRDS SAID THE SPEECH
MADE THEM FEEL PROUD.
AND A THIRD SAID IT MADE
THEM FEEL SAFER.
CHECK OUT THE DEMOCRAT
REACTION TODAY.
AND A MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
>> WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE THE
LOWEST POINT IN THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH LAST
NIGHT WAS WHEN HE SAYS
AMERICANS DREAM, TOO.
>> IT WAS DANGEROUS WHAT HE
SAID LAST NIGHT.
TALK ABOUT TEARS AND THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY BECAUSE
THAT'S A STATUE.
REALITY HERE IS THAT BY
REFLEXIVELY ATTACKING TRUMP,
WHILE PROVIDING NO POLICY
ALTERNATIVES, DEMOCRATS
UNDERCUT AND UNDERMINE THE
PUBLIC GOOD.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES
PROGRESSIVES.
BUT WHEN THERE IS ACTUAL
PROGRESS, THEY RECOIL.
NOW, THE LEFT ISN'T AFRAID
THAT TRUMP IS GOING TO FAIL,
NO WAY.
THEY ARE AFRAID THAT HE WILL
SUCCEED AND THEY ARE AFRAID
THAT HE IS SUCCEEDING RIGHT
NOW.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS
EARLIER TODAY.
I THINK THEIR HAPPIEST
MOMENT MAYBE SINCE ROY MOORE
YESTERDAY.
THEY WERE PROBABLY HOPING
THAT IT WOULD TAKE ANOTHER
NOSE DIVE TODAY AND THAT
WOULD BE A PERMANENT
DOWNTOWN.
IF AMERICA WERE A STOCK,
AND CHANGE TO NOPE AND
STRANGE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
GRIEVANCE INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
MAYBE A HODGEPODGE OF
LEFTIST RAGE AND HATE WITH
ONE GOAL IN MIND.
TO KEEP THEIR VOTERS ANGRY
AND RESENTFUL.
SO WHEN TRUMP ISSUED A CALL
LIKE, THIS THEY BECOME
UNHINGED.
>> WE CAN LIFT OUR CITIZENS
FROM WELFARE TO WORK, FROM
DEPENDENCE TO INDEPENDENCE
AND FROM POVERTY TO
PROSPERITY.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO HEAR THAT AND THEY
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT YOU TO
HEAR IT IT'S REALLY HARD TO
BELIEVE THIS THEY WANT US
WEAK AND POOR BECAUSE WHEN
YOU ARE WEAK, YOU NEED THEM
AND THEY THINK THEY CAN SELL
YOU ON BIG GOVERNMENT AND,
IN TURN, THEY HAVE MORE
POWER OVER YOUR LIFE.
NOW, LET'S FACE IT, THE
DEMOCRATS POLITICS OF
BITTERNESS, I THINK IT'S
PRETTY MUCH OUT OF GAS.
AND THEIR POST STATE OF THE
UNION TEMPER TANTRUMS SHOW
THEY TRIED REALLY HARD TO